bienvenidos estamos en el problema
número 6 y nos dicen si no hay residuos
cuantas yardas cuadradas de alfombra
necesitamos para cubrir un piso de 12
pies de ancho por 18 pies de largo nota
3 pies equivalen a una yarda ok
tenemos un piso más o menos así
así el cual tiene 12 pies de ancho
aquí tenemos 12 pies de gm que media de
herramienta aquí tengo 12 pies ok por 18
pies de largo por acá tengo 18 pies de
largo 18 pies y nos dan una nota que es
muy importante porque nos preguntan
cuántas yardas cuadradas yardas
cuadradas necesitamos de alfombra para
cubrir esta cantidad de piso que tenemos
quiero cubrir todo esto de alfombra ok
lo que me preguntan desde diadas y me
das la siguiente nota
a dos puntos tres pies tres pies
equivalen a una yarda ya ok y bueno para
que nos dan las yardas porque yo lo que
quiero saber es cuántas guiadas
cuadradas de alfombra necesitamos para
cumplir esto de aquí así que qué te
parece si de una vez transformó esta
cantidad y esta cantidad en yardas a ver
tengo 18 pies 18 pies a cuántas yardas
equivalen podemos ser una regla de 3 18
pies amplio saber esto y entonces 18 por
1 entre 3 me da 6 yardas seis yardas ok
es decir que 18 pies es lo mismo que 6
yardas lo voy a poner con este color
seis yardas muy bien y 12 pies pues lo
que tenemos que hacer es dividirlo entre
32 pies es lo mismo que 4 yardas y ahora
si tengo un terreno tengo un piso que
mide de ancho 4 yardas de largo 6 yardas
cuánto mide su área
enviadas bueno pues seis por cuatro me
va a dar 24 24 guiadas ya las cuadradas
es lo que mide este piso y ya esta es la
respuesta a este problema ojo ten
cuidado tú podrías cometer un grave
error si lo que haces es decir bueno voy
a multiplicar 18 por 12 y das ese
resultado 18 por 12 no va a ser tu
resultado porque esto está dado en 10
ten cuidado nuestra pregunta nos dice
cuántas yardas cuadradas necesitamos o
tal vez podrías tener otro error se me
ocurre que tal vez digas pues voy a
multiplicar 18 por 12 y lo voy a dividir
entre 3 porque una yarda son 3 pies y
esta va a ser la respuesta y eso también
está mal ten mucho cuidado porque si
nosotros tenemos aquí por ejemplo un
cuadrado que me da de aquí una yarda es
decir 3 pies
y de aquí también me da una yarda es
decir tres pies realmente no tenemos
tres pies cuadrados lo que tenemos son
nueve pies cuadrados emergente que aquí
tenemos 3 123 pies y por aquí también 3
pies
23 pies realmente lo que tenemos son 9
pies cuadrados 9 pies cuadrados que es 3
x 3 realmente si lo que quisiéramos es
obtener resultado por esta manera no
tendremos que dividirlo entre 3 no
tendremos que tomar 18 por 12 entre 9
porque son 9 los pies que nos quedan de
una yarda al cuadrado pero bueno esto se
ve mucho más largo que realmente
transformar todo desde un principio
transformar primeros y 8 pies de yardas
transformar primero 12 piezas halladas y
ya está muy bien problema número 6 vamos
a el problema número 7 el problema
número 7 que dice lo siguiente a una
persona conoce los pesos de un perro de
un gato y de un conejo tomados por pares
ay qué tierno y así obtuvo los
siguientes resultados a ver veamos que
me dice y me dice gato más conejos son 7
kilogramos
dato más conejo está voy a hacer es un
agente esto es igual a 7 kilogramos ok
esto por una parte por otra parte gato
más perros son 8 kilogramos dato más
estos son 8 kilogramos y por otra parte
conejo más perro son 9 kilogramos conejo
más perro esto es lo mismo que 9
kilogramos ok lo que me preguntan es
cuánto pesa el perro yo lo que quiero
saber es cuánto pesa el plano ok pues si
después tenemos un sistema de ecuaciones
con 13 cuestiones y tres incógnitas así
que podemos obtener el peso del perro
ahora para obtener el peso del perro
pues podremos trabajar mucho este
sistema de ecuaciones pero se me ocurre
qué te parece si nosotros nos fijamos
solamente las ecuaciones que tienen que
ver con el perro en este de aquí y en
estar aquí ya estas dos las puedes sumar
y después voy a utilizar esta ecuación
que tengo aquí que el gato más el
caballo no nomás el conejo son 7
kilogramos
ok sumamos estas dos primero y que me va
a quedar la suma de estas dos bueno pues
me queda
a gato conejo es gato más conejo estos
dos puede sumar después tengo perro más
perro pues esos dos veces pero dos veces
perro esto es igual a ocho más nueve
kilogramos ocho más nueve kilogramos son
17 kilogramos y aquí está de lujo porque
ya puedo utilizar esta ecuación de acá
arriba gato más conejo que es estos dos
datos más conejo es lo mismo que siete
kilogramos por lo tanto siete kilogramos
kilogramos más dos veces el perro esto
es igual a 17 kilogramos o dicho de otra
manera de que pueda restar 7 kilogramos
damos la reservación me va a quedar que
dos veces lo que empecé el perro es
igual a 10 kilogramos o lo que pesa el
perro que es lo que queremos son 5
kilogramos y esta es nuestra respuesta
cuando pues el perro el perro pesa 5
kilogramos ahora bien si tú quisieras
también el peso del gato y del conejo
pues ya puedes sustituir lo que pesa el
perro en estas dos ecuaciones
todos los demás pesos sin embargo
recuerda que estamos contra tiempo y ya
encontramos lo que queríamos el peso del
perro así que bueno este también estuvo
bastante fácil y además creo que es el
ejercicio más tierno y más lindo que he
resuelto en todos los problemas del st
pero vamos el siguiente el problema
número 8 problema número 8 y dice en una
maqueta un cuarto de centímetro
representa 16 metros en la vida real
ok un cuarto de centímetro un cuarto de
centímetro en la maqueta realmente lo
que me representa son 16 metros muy bien
y lo que me preguntan es a dice si
tenemos un camino de 40 metros de largo
es decir en la vida real tenemos un
camino de 40 metros al cual debe de ser
longitud en centímetros de su
representación en la maqueta ok pues que
lo que se le ponga regla de 3 realmente
no tenemos que preocuparnos tanto
un camino de 40 metros
a cuántos centímetros equivalen a
cuántos centímetros equivale pues vamos
a resolverlo tenemos que hacer este x
este y después dividirlo por este ok y
cuánto va a ser esto bueno pues nos va a
quedar 40 a esto lo voy a multiplicar
por un cuarto ya esto lo voy a dividir
entre 16 y esto es lo mismo que un 40
por un cuarto aquí podemos reducir de
una vez 40 por un cuarto es lo mismo que
10 esto es lo mismo que 10 sobre 16 y
esto es exactamente lo mismo que si saco
mitad de arriba y mi trabajo me quedan 5
octavos sin comentamos ya es una
fracción irreducible y entonces en mi
maqueta tengo que tener mucho cuidado
porque voy a poner cinco octavos de
centímetros y esto va a representar unos
40 metros de este camino que tengo en la
vida real
ahí está el problema número 8 tampoco
estaba tan difícil
solamente ten cuidado con las reglas de
3 vamos el siguiente problema
número 9 problemas número 9
y dice en el plano x en el punto p 0 es
el punto en donde se interceptan las dos
siguientes gráficas
y tengo dos ecuaciones vamos a ponerles
aquí
james es igual a equis cuadrada menos 9
y la otra es y es igual a menos x
cuadrada más 9 tengo estas dos
ecuaciones y estas dos ecuaciones se
intersectan en el punto p coma cero
donde p es un número positivo eso es lo
que me dice que es mayor que 0 ok lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale p ok pues
qué te parece tomamos una de estas dos
ecuaciones y tomamos la primera ecuación
y que me queda bueno pues que esta
ecuación se presenta con la otra en el
punto p 0 es decir que cuando x vale pn
y vale cero y si sustituimos esto en
esta ecuación me va a quedar que 0 es
igual a menos
+ 9 y de aquí quiero obtener el valor de
p entonces pues despejemos ap voy a
sumar p cuadrada de ambos lados de esta
ocasión aquí voy a sumar p cuadrada aquí
también voy a sumar p cuadrada y voy a
obtener que estos dos se van y me queda
que pep cuadrada es lo mismo que 9 o
dicho otra manera p es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 9 que esto es exactamente lo
mismo que 3 más menos 3 ojos recuerda
que cuando sacamos una raíz cuadrada
obtenemos dos valores uno positivo y el
otro negativo por lo tanto p vale más
menos 3 sin embargo nos dicen que debe
de ser positivo
este dato lo están viviendo en este
punto en el punto que está fijando p es
positivo y por lo tanto el valor de p
que nosotros queremos es 3 positivo que
es igual a 3 que es el inciso a esta es
mi respuesta de este problema número 9
lo único que tenemos que hacer es
sustituir estos
en esta ecuación o en la otra podríamos
sustituir en esta o en esta es un
distinto y de aquí darte cuenta que
podemos despejar apem y así obtener el
valor de p&o hay que tener en cuenta que
p es positivo ok vamos ser el problema
número 10 voy a borrar el pizarrón
espero que me dé tiempo de hacer el
problema número 10 así que vamos a
hacerlo rápido dice a la compañía
metalúrgica lozano tiene una vieja
máquina que produce 300 tornillos por
hora ok entonces la máquina vieja la
máquina vieja produce 300 tornillos
tornillos o qué
esto por ahora por ahora muy bien
después dicen si la compañía compra una
nueva máquina que produce 450 tornillos
por hora ok la nueva la nueva máquina
produce 450 tornillos
y los tornillos por ahora lo que me
preguntan es si se ponen a funcionar
ambas máquinas al mismo tiempo en
cuántos minutos en cuántos minutos
producirán ambas máquinas una cantidad
de 900 tornillos ok a ver lo que nos
preguntan está en minutos entonces vamos
a pasar esto de aquí esto de tim a
cuántos tornillos por minutos hacemos si
producimos 300 tornillos por hora a por
minutos cuántos vamos a producir bueno
pues hay que dividir esto entre 60 me va
a quedar 300 tornillos por ahora ya esto
lo voy a transformar a minutos entonces
lo voy a multiplicar por una hora que
tiene 60 minutos 60 minutos y cuántos
esto bueno pues esta hora se va con esta
hora 300 entre 60 es lo mismo que 55 2
niños por minuto por minuto hace la
máquina vieja ahora hablemos y pensemos
en la máquina nueva y voy a hacer lo
mismo como esta en tornillos program lo
voy a pasar a tornillos por minuto y
tengo 450 tornillos por ahora por ahora
esto lo voy a multiplicar por a lo que
vale una hora de minutos una hora vale
60 minutos 60 minutos y cuántos esto
bueno pues esto se va a ir con esto y me
va a quedar 450 entre 60 estos dos se
van y me queda 45 en 36 tornillos
por minuto por
que por cierto a 45 entre 6 se puede
reducir un poco si saco a tercera arriba
y tercera abajo esto es lo mismo que a
la tercera de 45 es 15 y la tercera de
seis es 2 15 medios de tornillos por
minuto
ahora lo que quiero producir son a 900
tornillos lo que me pregunto es en
cuántos minutos voy a producir así que
cinco tornillos por la cantidad de
minutos en los que les voy a producir le
voy a llamar x más 15 medios de
tornillos por 2 minutos que se van a
producir que es x esto debe de ser igual
a 900 ok estoy multiplicando por la
cantidad de minutos que necesito y
entonces cuántos esto bueno pues me
queda que a x es igual espera cuánto es
5 + 15 medios pues es lo mismo que 10
medios más 15 medios me va a dar 25
medios 25 medios 5 es lo mismo que 10
medio
diez medios más quince medios es 25
medios de x es igual a 900 y de aquí te
puedes pegar a x x es igual a 900 que va
a multiplicar al inverso multiplicativo
de éste es decir a 2 entre 25 recuerda
que lo que voy a hacer en esta ecuación
es multiplicar todo por 12 35 de tal
manera que esto se va a cancelar me va a
quedar que x es igual a 900 entre 25
esto es lo mismo que haciendo entre 25
es 44 por 9 36 36 por 2 o dicho de otra
manera es igual a 72
que por cierto es la respuesta de este
problema las dos máquinas se van a
tardar 72 minutos en conseguir 900
tornillos hasta la próxima